One question I get a lot is, "How do you
bridge the gap between two completely
different WHYs inside an organization?"
It's a good question it's especially
when you feel like you're working at
cross-purposes.
Now if it's done properly,
the WHY should be nested within something higher.
So for example, the United States has a WHY.
It's based on the Declaration of Independence,
all men are created equal, right.
Now within the United States,
we have nested WHYs.
Each state has a WHY,
each city has its own WHY.
In other words, Los Angeles has a very different WHY from New York.
Some people belong in New York,
some people belong in Los Angeles.
They are not the same.
But they're both distinctly American,
they belong in America.
Los Angeles wouldn't make sense
in France, it just wouldn't make sense.
So it's gonna be the same inside
an organization.
Operations may seem to have
a completely different WHY than marketing,
for example.
Just like Los Angeles or New York.
You either belong here or you
belong there.
But they should both feel like they fit in the
overarching WHY.
And that's actually how you
find common ground.
So when you feel like you're working at
cross-purposes,
the opportunity is to actually take it
up a level. In other words, you say,
hey, remember the WHY of this organization,
remember why this organization exists,
and we're both serving to advance that cause.
So that means we're working together,
we are cooperative.
So whenever you find that you're at each other
because you have different WHYs or
you feel like they're competing,
try and re-articulate that competition
as to cooperative.
We're cooperating together,
serving different ways,
in order to advance the greater good.
And that's how you find cooperation
with seeming competitive WHYs
inside the same organization.